le chantier de la mgen de la verrière
avance ce jeudi 21 juin les quatre pôles
de spécialités médicales qui
comprendront notamment deux centres de
santé mentale et un ehpad commence à
prendre forme sur le site de 37 hectares
après un lancement des travaux à l'été
2016 tout une première partie de
terrassement un gros volume de
terrassement à évacuer montage des grues
en avril 2017 et on est en train de
terminer la phase gros oeuvre des
bâtiments on a déjà des montées trois
des cinq grues nous reste deux grues en
place et les corps d'état techniques et
architecturaux ont bien démarré pour
rénover la zone plusieurs pavillons
construits dans les années 60 ont été
rasés les derniers bâtiments
rez-de-chaussée seront également détruit
dans les prochains mois et les patients
déplacer dans des structures
ultramodernes
une fois que le bat les bâtiments seront
réceptionnés les patients qui sont dans
les divers bat pavillon existants seront
transférés dans les nouveaux bâtiments
et nous viendrons détruire et finir les
espaces verts le but ultime étant que
les patients aient un lieu de vie dirais
à caractère non pas hospitalier mais
plutôt un caractère
deux résidences normal au total
établissement neuf comprendra 5 104 lits
95 de plus qu'avant la reconstruction
coût total de l'opération 80 millions
d'euros la livraison définitive est
prévue pour l'automne 2010 9